les chiens de navarre sont lâchés
difficile de résister au jeu de mots
mais le verbe mal interprété décrit
souvent la réalité cette compagnie avec
un bond à coucher dehors a été créé en
2005 par jean christophe maurice choisi
ce nom pour
des raisons personnelles je pense des
personnes dans sa famille sont
originaires de narabi n'a eu beaucoup de
recherches dans sa jeunesse qu'il a une
écriture collective et une envie
irrépressible d'écrire en temps réel
pour sortir d'un carcan théâtrale
convenu et bien pensants avec les
enfants ça en rajoute
l'objet du fil il attendra à retordre à
moudre
c'est sûr ionnaires on bruit on est dans
un 2 1 dans un théâtre qui qui qui est
ouvert qui est ouvert qui est un peu un
gouffre on se jette dans le gouffre un
petit peu chaque soir des créations au
nom plus qu'improbable l'autruche peut
mourir d'une crise cardiaque en
entendant le bruit d'une tondeuse à
gazon qui se met en marche c'est avec
les armoires normandes que les chiens de
navarre redécouvre la réunion l'amour
avec un grand a à faire rire ou pleurer
ou pleurer de rire d'amour et de haine
et d'amour et de mépris et de jalouses
peur on va lasser de le thème est vaste
mais c'est surtout le meurtre par
jalousie
et si la troupe s'autorise de bien
penser parfois à sa manière le bien
pensant et autres intellectualisation de
tout ce qui se passe dans notre société
embrumé n'est pas du tout l'écho de ce
qui se joue sur la scène
non parce que ce qu'est ce qui se passe
des passants général a tellement de
grain absurde qu'on ne peut pas nous
s'approprier un discours en face de ça
et adopter une position didactique ou
intellectuelles donc on a absolument
rien de d'intellectuels mais ça je pense
à soi tout de suite lui à kano entendent
par le quai est absolument de rien et
j'ai rien à rajouter
les chiens de navarre s'amuse sûrement
de tout mais tout en pudeur le rire ne
s'offusque pas et joyeux et libre à
vannes d'ascari robert à tizi de
comédiens participent au contre-pied des
chiens de navarre et cette liberté les
rend forcément heureux du moins en
apparence oui et tout va bien pas du
tout
comme quoi
dans dix ans bah y'a rien